Caption: so I'm gonna hand over now to Donna who
Caption: will be talking about creating a best
Caption: place to work the culture thanks diet hi
Caption: everyone I'm super excited to be here
Caption: today
Caption: before we get going I just want to give
Caption: a big thanks to the day-to-day
Caption: organizing committee and the billions of
Caption: volunteers that are here today helping
Caption: out and of course all of our sponsors
Caption: that gave us the cash all to do this
Caption: today and to make us such an awesome
Caption: event so thanks to all of them um so why
Caption: are we here well to hear about creating
Caption: a best place to work culture and winning
Caption: a best place to work awed but this talk
Caption: isn't just about how to win the award
Caption: it's about building a culture that's
Caption: actually deserving of an award I will
Caption: try and leave plenty of Q&A time at the
Caption: end and I'm really passionate about the
Caption: topic so please feel free to come and
Caption: talk to me later I'll be here right till
Caption: the end of the after-party so quite a
Caption: few of you know me already but for those
Caption: that don't I've been I've got 20 years
Caption: of experience building exceptional teams
Caption: within the IT industry my passion is
Caption: creating environments where people can
Caption: connect learn inspire and achieve and I
Caption: do this to my day job at ratify as a
Caption: state delivery manager as well as for a
Caption: whole bunch of not-for-profit community
Caption: groups as well such as witwer node
Caption: girl's purse play up her 80s women
Caption: dinner near Perth and sequel Saturday
Caption: over the past six months I've assisted
Caption: the rediff IWA team to grow from 20 to
Caption: 40 consultants and previous to the
Caption: sitting near I enabled the team to grow
Caption: from 20 to 120 and we were recognized
Caption: with a multitude of awards including the
Caption: number 8 and number 6 brw best place to
Caption: work award over the past six months I've
Caption: also built an event subcommittee for
Caption: Whitworth women in tech WI of five
Caption: people and we've grown the bimonthly
Caption: events from an average of 20 people to
Caption: 70 people per event and we've had
Caption: multiple events of over 200 people so
Caption: why why try and make your place the best
Caption: place to work the major reason is that
Caption: every company now has a tech company
Caption: and all of us know because we're all
Caption: most of us are intact there's a huge war
Caption: for talent so by creating the best place
Caption: to work
Caption: it helps you to attract and retain staff
Caption: and we've heard a bit about that in webs
Caption: in will Webster's talk people are our
Caption: competitive advantage and as an employee
Caption: one of the benefits is that you get to
Caption: enjoy where you work and work in a great
Caption: place so it's kind of a win-win for all
Caption: of us
Caption: so really interesting stats is that
Caption: right now on LinkedIn there are over two
Caption: and a half million IT jobs being
Caption: advertised at this very moment and in
Caption: Australia alone there's over 20,000 IT
Caption: jobs being advertised so to put that in
Caption: perspective
Caption: thousands of your competitors are also
Caption: fighting for the same candidates so most
Caption: of you have probably heard of work/life
Caption: balance right it's one of the first
Caption: things that I think about when I think
Caption: of best places to work and every company
Caption: that is trying to get staff is spreaking
Caption: work-life balance work life balance I
Caption: don't really believe in work-life
Caption: balance I believe that we've got one
Caption: life sorry its work-life integration is
Caption: what we should be calling it and I want
Caption: to tell you a little bit of story I
Caption: guess about why I feel that way and and
Caption: something that's shaped my life
Caption: so I was 17 years old and I was at a
Caption: shopping center and my lunch break and I
Caption: looked at my watch and I was like crap
Caption: I'm running late again to get back to
Caption: work for those of you that know me
Caption: nothing much has changed I'm always
Caption: running late for everything so I run
Caption: towards I raced towards the traffic
Caption: lights don't run I walk because I still
Caption: don't run I walk so walk as quickly as I
Caption: can towards a traffic light and I look
Caption: at the lights
Caption: it's a six-lane highway my works just
Caption: across the road and there's a little red
Caption: man and I'm like I don't have time to
Caption: wait for the green man who waits for the
Caption: green man
Caption: so look left look right and I run the
Caption: next thing I remember is an intensely
Caption: loud sound of cars zooming past me and I
Caption: couldn't see anything but I could just
Caption: hear this zoom
Caption: zooom and it was so intensely loud and i
Caption: remember being afraid because i was like
Caption: oh my god a car's gonna hit me and I
Caption: tried to try to roll up my legs because
Caption: I think at that point I was laying down
Caption: and I couldn't move the next thing I
Caption: remember was the sound of my friends and
Caption: colleagues voice Leanne and she said to
Caption: me you in an ambulance Donna
Caption: everything's gonna be okay the next
Caption: thing I remember was the sound of a
Caption: voice saying we can't move her we've got
Caption: a need to cut off her clothes and I must
Caption: have started I must have been starting
Caption: to come around a little bit by this
Caption: stage because all I could think was oh
Caption: my god please don't cut off my clothes I
Caption: had a work uniform on and it accussed me
Caption: 120 dollars and at 17 years old only 75%
Caption: of the adult wage so I was like a whole
Caption: week's salary but they did anyway the
Caption: next thing I remember was actually
Caption: waking up and I was in a hospital and my
Caption: family were there and there was a doctor
Caption: showing through some x-rays telling me
Caption: that everything was okay and I didn't
Caption: have any broken bones or any injuries
Caption: other than a few scratches on my fingers
Caption: what I found out later and this was by
Caption: talking to the driver obviously you
Caption: probably figured out I got hit by a car
Caption: and talking to the lady who was driving
Caption: the car who was way more traumatized by
Caption: the whole event than me she said that
Caption: she saw me standing on the side of the
Caption: road and she thought I looked directly
Caption: at her and then I just ran straight in
Caption: front of her and she was going 60
Caption: kilometers an hour and she didn't have
Caption: time to even put on her brakes so I
Caption: rolled onto the carb on it
Caption: I smashed the windscreen broke up with
Caption: my head my head was pretty sore for a
Caption: while after that and landed on the
Caption: ground on the other side of the car so
Caption: that whole experience for me was an
Caption: incredible experience because it really
Caption: made me realize that I could have been
Caption: gone my life could have been over and I
Caption: wouldn't have had any morning I didn't
Caption: see the car I had no idea I was
Caption: unconscious for hours and it just could
Caption: have been over I wouldn't have had a
Caption: chance to take things off my bucket list
Caption: or have regrets it just would have been
Caption: gone
Caption: so for me that experience has really
Caption: shaped the whole way that I live my life
Caption: I believe that life is too short and you
Caption: can be gone tomorrow so make today count
Caption: and do what you want to do and do what
Caption: you enjoy doing and on that we have the
Caption: power to choose we have the power to
Caption: choose how we live a life where we work
Caption: what we do every day what goals to set
Caption: and how we make a difference in this
Caption: world and the talk earlier today on
Caption: making a difference in the world was
Caption: amazing and you know we all have that
Caption: choice now some of us don't know what we
Caption: want to do we don't know what we enjoy
Caption: we don't know what our passion is so if
Caption: you don't know that's okay but there's
Caption: tools that there are out there to help
Caption: figure that out I'm a big fan of simon
Caption: Sinek and his model of the Golden Circle
Caption: and we'll had that in his talk earlier
Caption: as well I feel like there's going to be
Caption: quite a few things that Will's already
Caption: covered but that's good
Caption: but in his book how to find your why it
Caption: really talks you through some practical
Caption: steps of how to figure out what those
Caption: passion areas are and what it is that
Caption: you enjoy and what it is that you should
Caption: be doing with your life so I'd highly
Caption: recommend it the other technique that
Caption: I've used before and and I recommend is
Caption: to think about if you unload like we all
Caption: think about oh my god like what if I
Caption: want a lotto but actually think it
Caption: through
Caption: so think about sure I might travel the
Caption: world for 12 months or do some crazy
Caption: stuff for 12 months but then after that
Caption: when that stuff starts to get a little
Caption: boring how do you feel your time what
Caption: does your life look like and if you
Caption: really reflect on that you know then you
Caption: can start thinking about well how can I
Caption: turn that into something that I can make
Caption: money out of and it can be my job and
Caption: you know what this is trial and error so
Caption: don't be afraid to fail
Caption: I've had lots of different careers from
Caption: childcare to recruitment to HR to
Caption: delivery management just keep following
Caption: whatever it is that makes you happy and
Caption: whatever it is that you enjoy and a
Caption: passionate about look for the comments
Caption: look for sideways moves within your
Caption: company if you want to try out different
Caption: roles
Caption: and look for sideways moves to other
Caption: companies if you want to try out new
Caption: companies one of the other great things
Caption: that I read recently was the book the
Caption: subtle art of not giving a Fu CK and I
Caption: am getting recorded so I don't think I
Caption: can say that word but it's an awesome
Caption: book and one of the best tips out of
Caption: that book was that our brains love
Caption: solving problems so if we solve all of
Caption: the problems our brain will create more
Caption: problems for us so when you're living
Caption: your life and when you're looking at
Caption: your job find a job that has problems
Caption: that you enjoy solving because you're
Caption: just gonna need to keep continuously
Caption: solving them because that's what our
Caption: brains love doing so that was a really
Caption: big Segway into building best place to
Caption: work culture but there were two main
Caption: points that I wanted to make one is that
Caption: it's no one else's job a responsibility
Caption: to make you happy at work only you have
Caption: that power
Caption: Patrick's talk was great and just then
Caption: for anyone that heard in on toxic
Caption: developers and one of the things around
Caption: that is internal versus external locus
Caption: of control and if people haven't read up
Caption: on locus of control as most of you
Caption: probably have but have a bit of a rate
Caption: of it because if you're not sure whether
Caption: maybe you are a toxic developer external
Caption: locus of control is generally where they
Caption: focus you internal locus of control
Caption: means that you have that have the power
Caption: to control your actions how you react
Caption: your behaviors how you reframe things we
Caption: have that power ourselves and the other
Caption: thing is that all of us as employees
Caption: have the power to help make the place we
Caption: work a best place to work it will happen
Caption: a lot quicker if you don't rely on HR or
Caption: managers to do it for you
Caption: one of my consultants recently came up
Caption: to me and told me about some issues that
Caption: he saw with the grad program and he
Caption: asked me whether he could have some time
Caption: dedicated to owning it and running it
Caption: and I'm putting in place some of these
Caption: solutions I was like hell yes so if you
Caption: go to a leader with a problem and with
Caption: the solution and you want to own it and
Caption: drive it most leaders are gonna say yes
Caption: but if you don't ask you don't get so
Caption: the actual award itself there's lots of
Caption: different culture Awards one of the
Caption: biggest ones used to be what was known
Caption: as the
Caption: brw best place to work award made by
Caption: done by great place to work now one of
Caption: the main reasons for getting an award
Caption: like this under your belt
Caption: is staff attraction in tech most of us
Caption: know that we're not just looking for
Caption: local candidates we're looking for
Caption: candidates from interstate and from
Caption: overseas now when they're looking and
Caption: comparing all these different companies
Caption: that are advertising because we know
Caption: there's twenty thousand job adverts out
Caption: there just in Australia alone what are
Caption: they looking for every company says yeah
Caption: we're awesome we've got a great culture
Caption: come work for us so if you can tie a
Caption: award on to all of that marketing
Caption: material and your employer branding it
Caption: straight away it gives candidates
Caption: something a bit more tangible and they
Caption: can go you know what this company must
Caption: be a great place to work because they've
Caption: been awarded something they've gone
Caption: through a process and they've been given
Caption: an award so it's a really really good
Caption: tool and I guess a specific example of
Caption: how this worked for me as someone
Caption: recruiting staff previously I don't know
Caption: if anyone's use LinkedIn to recruit
Caption: staff but they have a program they have
Caption: in mails so you can send emails to
Caption: people that you don't know and and
Caption: approach them and try and connect with
Caption: them to get them to come through your
Caption: interview recruitment process are in
Caption: male response rate the acceptance rate
Caption: went up by over 25% after we had an
Caption: award just by writing on that email
Caption: we're number eight best place to work or
Caption: we're number six best place to work
Caption: 25% increase in acceptance which is huge
Caption: I think the average acceptance rate is
Caption: about 8% of in mouth it's super super
Caption: low so how do I actually win one with
Caption: the brw award there's two main
Caption: components the first one is a culture
Caption: survey so a great place to work send out
Caption: an anonymous survey to all of your staff
Caption: the main tip here is that it's a really
Caption: high completion rate that you need it's
Caption: about 95 percent so you do need to let
Caption: your staff know that there is a survey
Caption: coming and please can you fill it out
Caption: and obviously you want to hope that
Caption: they're going to say good things
Caption: otherwise there's no point the second
Caption: part is a document where they ask you a
Caption: whole heap of questions about how you do
Caption: things and I guess the main thing I want
Caption: to make clear here is they're not
Caption: looking for
Caption: policies procedures blah blah blah
Caption: although you know if you've got some of
Caption: those you can add them but they're
Caption: looking for real-life examples they're
Caption: looking for pictures they're looking for
Caption: quotes from your employees they're
Caption: looking for stories about your employees
Caption: they actually want real pictures our
Caption: second for our second submission for a
Caption: further mission we had some marketing
Caption: help because we've never done it before
Caption: and we didn't know where to start
Caption: for our second submission based on the
Caption: feedback we've gotten I just wrote it
Caption: myself because they don't care about it
Caption: being all schmack and amazing they just
Caption: want to know the real stories so if
Caption: you've got great stories and you can get
Caption: your people to tell them and put that
Caption: into a document that's what they're
Caption: looking for
Caption: so specifically how you drive things
Caption: like communication across the company
Caption: how you thank your employees how you
Caption: make them feel welcome when they join
Caption: how you're transparent across your
Caption: organization is a big one how you enable
Caption: career progression and then real life
Caption: stories for all of those things so in
Caption: terms of what actually makes a great
Caption: place to work in my experience it's
Caption: these six main areas
Caption: so a best place to work is all about
Caption: culture and what is culture culture is
Caption: values beliefs and behaviors that are
Caption: shared and demonstrated across your
Caption: company there's some common themes in
Caption: text in turkey around values around the
Caption: Facebook's the Amazons the googles of
Caption: the world and they're around ownership
Caption: collaboration learning and innovation so
Caption: there's some of the key ones that come
Caption: up again and again and again ideally
Caption: though you want to involve your team's
Caption: collaboratively when you come up with
Caption: these values or beliefs because I think
Caption: we all know one person doesn't make a
Caption: culture every single person in your
Caption: organization do so ensuring that you're
Caption: picking the right ones
Caption: and that everyone's on board with them
Caption: is really important otherwise they won't
Caption: be shared values and your company does
Caption: that need to be a startup to do this you
Caption: can do this with an existing company at
Caption: ratify for example Rob Moore led the
Caption: charge to create some core beliefs that
Caption: you see up here today and this was only
Caption: 12 months ago so he did this with a
Caption: group of people and they did it on
Caption: Yammer completely transparently and
Caption: collaboratively I made got engagement
Caption: from people they've got people to talk
Caption: about what they wanted their beliefs to
Caption: be what they thought our culture was
Caption: what we wanted this to look like and by
Caption: choosing these collaboratively it means
Caption: that people have really bought into them
Caption: and owning them and drive them when I
Caption: first joined my previous company igneel
Caption: we had about 25 people at the time and
Caption: they hadn't gone through that process of
Caption: creating shared values so it was easy so
Caption: I reached out to all of the staff I got
Caption: everybody involved in it was a bit old
Caption: school email and phone and stuff you
Caption: know back in the day quite a few years
Caption: ago now and I got people to talk to me
Caption: about you know what they thought I
Caption: culture was they wanted it to be I got
Caption: them to send me pictures or words or
Caption: stories to describe what they wanted it
Caption: to look like and we came up with our
Caption: values collaboratively and that was one
Caption: of the key reasons that helped us to
Caption: double in size over 12 months and to win
Caption: at s place to work award so it's a
Caption: really important part the other major
Caption: component of shared values is rewarding
Caption: the behavior that you want to encourage
Caption: and also thinking about the stories that
Caption: you tell as well around the behavior you
Caption: want to encourage I was at an event a
Caption: few weeks ago now and it was quite a
Caption: high-profile person who was speaking and
Caption: she was talking about telling stories to
Caption: drive your culture and behavior and I
Caption: was like yeah ton of percent totally
Caption: agree anyway she was talking about in
Caption: the interview process so instead of in
Caption: an interview saying this is the criteria
Caption: we want these are our expectations
Caption: telling the candidate a story about your
Caption: culture and about people in your
Caption: organization who you're you're rewarding
Caption: and our examples of the behavior that
Caption: you want to portray and she told this
Caption: story about a graduate and there was a
Caption: graduate working on a team project and
Caption: the project was due on Monday and the
Caption: graduate came in has spent the entire
Caption: weekend working on this project to
Caption: really take it to the next level so that
Caption: on the Monday when they delivered this
Caption: this project to the customer the
Caption: customer was absolutely blown away it
Caption: was fantastic and she was talking about
Caption: you know how awesome this grad was
Caption: because they went above and beyond and
Caption: they really you know made this produce
Caption: project a success and for me I was
Caption: thinking about it and I was like do I
Caption: want my graduate on my staff to come in
Caption: and work or weekend on a project know
Caption: you know do I want the hero complex of
Caption: one person coming in and putting in a
Caption: whole heap of hours to make something
Caption: awesome instead of working with a team
Caption: know so for me when I thought about that
Caption: story it displayed a culture that I
Caption: wouldn't want for my company so you need
Caption: to be really careful about these stories
Caption: that you tell because that's what
Caption: actually drives your culture this is a
Caption: huge area and definitely one of the most
Caption: important although I probably say that
Caption: about all of them
Caption: but everyone knows you don't leave
Caption: companies right you leave managers so
Caption: how about instead of having managers we
Caption: have leaders and I want to make it clear
Caption: that anyone can be a leader you don't
Caption: need to have a manager title or being a
Caption: senior position to act like a leader
Caption: I've been upwards managing and leading
Caption: for much much longer than having a
Caption: specific manager title title can help
Caption: absolutely but it's not
Caption: necessary people follow great leaders
Caption: and so the title will come if you
Caption: actually behave like a leader so if you
Caption: do want to win the best place to work
Caption: award you need to have good leaders if
Caption: they have gaps provide them with
Caption: training there's so much great
Caption: leadership training out there we
Caption: recently had a session with a consultant
Caption: from Sydney named Georgia emerge and it
Caption: was around specifically communication
Caption: for leaders and one of the best tips she
Caption: gave was nip it in the bud
Caption: nip things in the bud so if you see
Caption: something that's a bit of an issue jump
Caption: on it quickly before it escalates and
Caption: things will be a lot easier and I think
Caption: some of that resonates you know with
Caption: perhaps to talk again about toxic
Caption: developers if you see little issues jump
Caption: on them quickly in early illuminate
Caption: group is the local W a company and they
Caption: do some awesome training around
Caption: innovation and also general leadership
Caption: courses they also have a course that's
Caption: run through the department training so
Caption: it's family subsidized by the government
Caption: which means that it's cost effective and
Caption: it's awesome
Caption: win-win so there's there's really no
Caption: shortage available I'm also I also work
Caption: with a company called coach connect so
Caption: it's kind of the same principle as an
Caption: EAP offering to your staff but it's
Caption: actually coaching so it's the self
Caption: development and self improvement so if
Caption: you're interested in any type of
Caption: training always happy to talk about that
Caption: stuff and connect you with anybody that
Caption: I know later on
Caption: so some of the main areas as a
Caption: leadership team that the leadership team
Caption: needs to focus on is autonomy mastery
Caption: and purpose and once again we'll cover
Caption: this you know Dan pink in his talk as
Caption: well the leadership team needs to set
Caption: the vision where are we going and why
Caption: and then provide the empowerment in the
Caption: ownership for the team to figure out how
Caption: we get there
Caption: and obviously the leadership teams there
Caption: to support them but let your team be
Caption: empowered to own it and come up with the
Caption: how task driven environments are gone or
Caption: going firstly task driven jobs are the
Caption: first ones getting replaced and
Caption: automated and secondly younger
Caption: generations aren't interested in task
Caption: driven jobs anymore
Caption: there's no fulfillment in them so it
Caption: needs to be more than that
Caption: the other benefit with providing
Caption: ownership and empowerment is that
Caption: flexibility doesn't become an issue
Caption: anymore because it doesn't matter when
Caption: or where people are working because
Caption: they've got things that they own and
Caption: that they're accountable to deliver so
Caption: you don't have to worry about that
Caption: flexibility conversation anymore there's
Caption: heaps and starts to show you that
Caption: people's primary reason for coming to
Caption: work isn't money so leaders need to give
Caption: them more than that they need to inspire
Caption: and set a vision the other key area is
Caption: transparency
Caption: once again that's been touched on
Caption: already transparency and clear
Caption: expectations what equals success and how
Caption: a decisions made one of the things that
Caption: I've been very impressed with are
Caption: working at ratify is the level of
Caption: transparency so our intranet can be
Caption: edited by anyone across the organization
Caption: and it contains literally everything it
Caption: hooks up to power bi which reports on
Caption: all of our revenue across the
Caption: organization how much what are all of
Caption: the rates are the charge out rates for
Caption: consultants like literally anything to
Caption: do with financials are all completely
Caption: transparent all of our targets as well
Caption: are all completely transparent for
Caption: everyone across the organization
Caption: decision making Yammer Yammer is used
Caption: for probably 95 percent of the
Caption: decision-making and it's completely
Caption: collaborative and open so leaders and
Caption: and anybody can post something on Yama I
Caption: think we should do this looking at a new
Caption: initiative and everybody can just jump
Caption: on give their opinion and and implement
Caption: something if it all goes well
Caption: another thing is flatter structures so a
Caption: ratify instead of having a state manager
Caption: we have a leadership group and that
Caption: leadership group collaboratively makes
Caption: decisions and set strategies and for the
Caption: state so slotter structure is something
Caption: that again and again is coming up that
Caption: people are looking for now in new
Caption: company design another key area is
Caption: empathy and emotional intelligence now
Caption: in my opinion you can't be a leader if
Caption: you don't have these might be harsh but
Caption: that's my opinion I've seen so many tech
Caption: people promoted in the past because
Caption: they're a subject matter expert in what
Caption: they do and the only way to move up to
Caption: the next role was to be a manager
Caption: leader but they have a hater because
Caption: they actually don't enjoy the role
Caption: because it's not what they want to do
Caption: well they're just really terrible at it
Caption: because they're not interested in
Caption: getting to know people replacing
Caption: yourself great leaders look to replace
Caption: themselves we're moving to a very
Caption: different way of working in job design
Caption: now you know back in the day there was
Caption: this linear career pathway so you had to
Caption: really protect your role because only
Caption: you could have that role and there was
Caption: only one way to go and you want it to
Caption: protect it so that you could get that
Caption: job it's not like that anymore so as a
Caption: leader if you can mentor and upskill
Caption: people around you to replace yourself
Caption: there's so many new jobs getting created
Caption: every day that you can move into so you
Caption: don't have to have that fear anymore and
Caption: this one was definitely covered already
Caption: is leading by example and practicing
Caption: what you preach this is one of the
Caption: witwer events we had a few months ago
Caption: with some of my role models up here and
Caption: hi Mandy but you know at this at this
Caption: event on role models it these ladies
Caption: share their stories of leaders who
Caption: inspired them throughout their career
Caption: the quickest way to build trust and
Caption: respect is getting hands-on with your
Caption: team so be prepared to do whatever they
Caption: they have to do and always do what you
Caption: say your drew I've worked for so many
Caption: leaders they don't do this but it's such
Caption: a simple thing do what you say you would
Caption: do if you say you'll be somewhere at a
Caption: certain time you know sometimes maybe a
Caption: couple of minutes late but be there at a
Caption: certain time if you say you're gonna go
Caption: to a meeting go to that meeting and if
Caption: anything changes let people know there's
Caption: nothing worse than managers that just
Caption: don't rock up for a meeting and you've
Caption: rescheduled things to be there and they
Caption: don't see that you're valuable enough or
Caption: important enough to attend it's just a
Caption: massive what was the walk of the dead
Caption: culture thing whatever that was that was
Caption: awesome so things like stacking the
Caption: dishwasher as a leader if you you know
Caption: things like that getting coffee for the
Caption: team as a leader all these little things
Caption: it's amazing how much credibility and
Caption: respect you'll get from doing these
Caption: things and being authentic and genuine
Caption: as well I talked to about Georgia Murch
Caption: do
Caption: the training for us recently and one of
Caption: the best sayings that she had just blew
Caption: my mind
Caption: it was people here you're content but
Caption: they smell your intent and so my god
Caption: like it literally just blew my mind
Caption: because it's so so true and for me that
Caption: is all about authenticity so people hear
Caption: your content but they smell your intent
Caption: if you're not genuine people will know
Caption: if you've got an agenda people will know
Caption: people are the most important part of
Caption: any business in my opinion it might be a
Caption: little bias because I do love people but
Caption: seriously you know people are a
Caption: competitive advantage and we're quite a
Caption: way away still from having AI with the
Caption: level of AI and empathy to replace
Caption: people completely and this is my lovely
Caption: team here all adorable I think they're
Caption: all here today most of them here today
Caption: and hiring is one of the biggest
Caption: challenges for organizations right so
Caption: getting great people and once again
Caption: we'll touched on that in his talk as
Caption: well earlier today if you look at the
Caption: sponsors who's hiring out of the
Caption: sponsors like seriously all of them so
Caption: we're all trying to hire and without
Caption: giving people training around hiring
Caption: people just hire people like themselves
Caption: we just default to hiring people who we
Caption: get along with and who are the same as
Caption: us hiring for culture fit can just be an
Caption: excuse for this to hire people that you
Caption: like and that you get along with so you
Caption: need to create some structure and some
Caption: real interview questions that are around
Caption: your values and your beliefs so they're
Caption: not about this gray culture they're
Caption: about your values and your beliefs
Caption: specific examples of how people
Caption: demonstrate those values great people
Caption: want to work with great people and it
Caption: really builds momentum so in the three
Caption: companies that I've that have most
Caption: recently worked with creating a best
Caption: place to work culture and hiring great
Caption: people has increased our refer increase
Caption: the referral hiring rate over 50% of all
Caption: hires and I've seen it get as high as
Caption: 75% so if you can have great people and
Caption: create that momentum hiring becomes a
Caption: no-brainer
Caption: I can't ratify we've got we've literally
Caption: got you know a line of people waiting to
Caption: join us because we have great
Caption: people and our referral process is just
Caption: so huge and so strong so on that help
Caption: your employees with their personal
Caption: branding there's no you know back in the
Caption: day I've worked for companies that have
Caption: been afraid to promote their people
Caption: because they might leave it's the
Caption: opposite if you give you people that
Caption: that help and you know you pay for them
Caption: to go to conferences and you give them
Caption: training so that they can speak at
Caption: conferences and you help them with their
Caption: LinkedIn profiles it comes back it comes
Caption: back so much more and find out where the
Caption: people that you want to hire are and
Caption: then get involved in things like
Caption: sponsorship which is what you know all
Caption: of us sponsors today are doing if you
Caption: know we're the people that you're
Caption: looking to hire are then get involved in
Caption: community engagement and build your own
Caption: employee brand through your people so
Caption: you know who use your pitch like use
Caption: your people that's terrible I don't mean
Caption: you to people but no one's like that but
Caption: there's the asking people if they if
Caption: they can you know do a little video or
Caption: put a quote on and and then promote that
Caption: on your LinkedIn and on your website so
Caption: get your people to help be part of your
Caption: brand one of the coolest things I've
Caption: seen that some companies are starting to
Caption: do is create this role dream manager it
Caption: sounds a little bit like whatever but
Caption: seriously so it's not once again
Caption: work-life integration not work-life
Caption: balance so if you want to have engaged
Caption: passionate people
Caption: why just help your people on their
Caption: career while I have a bigger
Caption: conversation about their life and who
Caption: they are you know what are you
Caption: passionate about what are your goals and
Caption: then how can we help you with all of
Caption: them not just your career we really need
Caption: to think bigger about engaging people
Caption: and helping people because if they're
Caption: passionate and they love their life
Caption: they're gonna work harder and be happier
Caption: at work it's a win-win for all of us and
Caption: this is a hot topic as always I can't
Caption: wait till it's not a separate
Caption: conversation and that it's just the way
Caption: that we do things right but for now it's
Caption: still a separate conversation there are
Caption: so many stats from all across the globe
Caption: around financial performance and company
Caption: success with diversity versus without
Caption: diversity
Caption: a recent McKinsey study showed that
Caption: companies were 15% more likely to be
Caption: above the medium financial returns if
Caption: they had gender diversity but 35% more
Caption: likely to be above financial return
Caption: performance with racial and ethnic
Caption: diversity so it's a huge conversation
Caption: and it shouldn't be a conversation it
Caption: just is it's just factual we just need
Caption: to have companies that have diversity
Caption: and we need to hire for diversity and
Caption: what we were saying about team makeup
Caption: it's exactly this it's it's that it's
Caption: having diversity across your team's will
Caption: make your team's more successful and
Caption: make your company more successful the
Caption: study also showed that companies without
Caption: diversity were in the bottom 25% and
Caption: that's huge so it's a it's a no-brainer
Caption: so educate your teams on the benefits of
Caption: diversity and provide unconscious bias
Caption: training lots of us don't even know the
Caption: biases that we have listening to Will's
Caption: talkin I saw I keep referring to rules
Caption: talk but it was really good but when he
Caption: started talking about and I don't know
Caption: if anyone else experiences but when he
Caption: started talking about the different
Caption: roles that you have all the different
Caption: hats within a team and he had the the
Caption: first one was at the lead lead engineer
Caption: or something and he said she and he
Caption: referred to she when he talks through
Caption: she would do this and she will do that
Caption: she will do this and I was like oh
Caption: that's weird
Caption: like you know because he just becomes so
Caption: used to automatically thinking in your
Caption: brain lead engineer he like he just it's
Caption: just automatic it's one of these
Caption: unconscious biases that we're so used to
Caption: and when he did the same she she she I
Caption: was like this is really weird
Caption: have anything I've ever heard that
Caption: before it was amazing and things like
Caption: you know please don't ask the woman in
Caption: the room to take the minutes seriously
Caption: um embrace differences so we all know
Caption: the best teams the best teams have
Caption: diverse views and opinions so healthy
Caption: conflict and debate is a really really
Caption: good thing it helps us to push you to
Caption: others boundaries to come up with better
Caption: solutions calling people out on biases
Caption: and inappropriate behavior don't
Caption: tolerate it lead by example
Caption: and be open-minded to learning and
Caption: having conversations in my talk last
Caption: year which was around attracting and
Caption: wrote and retention for women in tech I
Caption: got some speak
Caption: I got some feedback afterwards in the
Caption: anonymous survey around terminologies so
Caption: using female as opposed to woman and
Caption: I've never really thought about that
Caption: before and then I met Vee Prendergast
Caption: who many of you probably know CEO of
Caption: stir-fry studios and a wit we're event a
Caption: few months back and I asked her like if
Caption: she wouldn't mind having answering some
Caption: questions and having a bit of a chat
Caption: because I hadn't really worked with
Caption: anyone in transgender before so she was
Caption: amazing I had all these like silly
Caption: questions and she gave me all this
Caption: information about you know how like
Caption: terminology and if females a real
Caption: biological term so transgender women
Caption: prefer women woman as opposed to female
Caption: but all these little things that I just
Caption: would have never thought about so people
Caption: will be happy to educate you if you're
Caption: genuine and you actually want to learn
Caption: and want to improve and want to create
Caption: an inclusive environment so don't be
Caption: afraid to ask what may be silly
Caption: questions love silly questions also
Caption: inclusivity around you know having
Caption: prayer rooms being aware of cultural
Caption: events providing spaces for
Caption: breastfeeding breast pumping all of
Caption: those types of considerations that we
Caption: may not make because it doesn't affect
Caption: us think about who's in your
Caption: organization think about who might be
Caption: joining and then create an inclusive
Caption: environment thankfully paid maternity
Caption: and paternity leave is starting to
Caption: become a norm which is amazing and also
Caption: paid superannuation while on leave is
Caption: also starting to become a norm a bit of
Caption: a shout out to a work 180 I think
Caption: they've done an incredible job there
Caption: they're a job board I think they've done
Caption: a great job of targeting diversity
Caption: candidates but also encouraging
Caption: employers to improve on their their
Caption: benefits and considerations to be able
Caption: to advertise if you haven't heard of
Caption: wgea the workplace gender equality
Caption: agency there's a free application and
Caption: accreditation you can get that is
Caption: another part of becoming a best place to
Caption: work having those sorts of things under
Caption: your belt and lastly on this one
Caption: flexibility for everyone not just women
Caption: or parents let's create an environment
Caption: where flexibility and diversity is just
Caption: the way that we work there's nothing
Caption: special about it it's just the norm and
Caption: the sooner this happens the better for
Caption: all of us
Caption: women and men I've worked with quite a
Caption: few men and women who both work who will
Caption: work part time not because I have kids
Caption: but because they have passions and
Caption: hobbies outside of work and they want to
Caption: have time to do those and that's awesome
Caption: there's nothing wrong with that so let's
Caption: just embrace the general flexibility
Caption: conversation
Caption: honestly Career Development I think
Caption: needs a complete redesign through our
Caption: workplaces of the future but that is
Caption: much longer conversation and a whole
Caption: talk in itself and I don't know all the
Caption: answers but I think there's a huge
Caption: amount of work that we need to do here
Caption: in the meantime though in order to be a
Caption: best place to work you do need to have
Caption: clear transparent and objective
Caption: processes so that people can have
Caption: control over their own career paths you
Caption: also need to make the salary
Caption: conversations easier and more structured
Caption: in a previous company we used to do
Caption: reviews behind the scenes so we'd have a
Caption: look at people's salaries and if there
Caption: was people outside of market raid or
Caption: vans we would proactively contact them
Caption: and give them a salary review but what
Caption: this man is if people weren't outside
Caption: the band's they didn't get a review
Caption: unless they come and asked us and we all
Caption: know there's lots of stats that show
Caption: that women are less inclined to ask for
Caption: salary reviews but in my experience a
Caption: lot of men that I've worked with as well
Caption: especially you know if you might be a
Caption: little bit more introverted also don't
Caption: like asking for those conversations so
Caption: as a as a best place employer create an
Caption: opportunity where everyone can have a
Caption: conversation they know what's going to
Caption: happen and know when it can happen and
Caption: make the conversation as easy as
Caption: possible if you can provide them with
Caption: you know some salary bans or some
Caption: information to help them with the
Caption: conversation make it easy for people and
Caption: make it fair and it's not always about
Caption: promotions it's often not about
Caption: promotions actually it's about growing
Caption: and developing so think about the way
Caption: that you do performance reviews and
Caption: rather than old-school meaningless
Caption: performance reviews modernize it at
Caption: ratify we use the retro process so most
Caption: of you have probably worked in agile and
Caption: and know what retros are if you haven't
Caption: feel free to come and talk to anyone at
Caption: ratify or bank Quest or probably anyone
Caption: or our
Caption: so retro they're all about improving and
Caption: learning and feedback so mate so we
Caption: don't have a once-a-year performance
Caption: review we just have retros as often as
Caption: people want to do them so some people do
Caption: them quarterly some people do them every
Caption: six months and it's all about learning
Caption: and improving and setting goals the last
Caption: sort of main area from a leadership
Caption: perspective is collaboration in
Caption: connection it's human nature to want
Caption: connection and in consulting this can be
Caption: a real challenge because you've got
Caption: people that are working out on gigs
Caption: sometimes for you know six months at a
Caption: time so you really need to create a
Caption: structure for connection points I ratify
Caption: we have an eight-week onboarding process
Caption: everybody has a buddy that has ketchups
Caption: with them regularly everyone has the
Caption: people partner and the people partner
Caption: does regular catch ups they have a line
Caption: manager they have principal consultant
Caption: and then they have a leadership group as
Caption: well so all of these different touch
Caption: points proactively contact people and
Caption: and catch up with them for a coffee or
Caption: just to see how they're going this isn't
Caption: because people need help this is just
Caption: because people want to feel valued and
Caption: you want it to feel like a community so
Caption: you just need to have his regular touch
Caption: points communication methods and avenues
Caption: can be a tricky one because there's so
Caption: many you know is that thanks Microsoft
Caption: is it teens is it Yama is it email is it
Caption: slack where do we go so making sure that
Caption: you communicate how people connect
Caption: throughout your company where do you go
Caption: to connect and make it easier and then
Caption: creating opportunities for a group
Caption: collaboration and connection is really
Caption: important as well
Caption: and at different times so when you're
Caption: creating the group connection
Caption: opportunities you need to make sure that
Caption: you consider it once again do you have
Caption: people that work part time and they
Caption: don't work on different days do you have
Caption: people who have to leave early because
Caption: they have to you know take the kids
Caption: think the kids up from school are you
Caption: doing family events but do you have
Caption: people that don't have families and then
Caption: will they really be included you kind of
Caption: really need to think about all of your
Caption: people and create lots of different
Caption: opportunities for group collaboration
Caption: also group times in
Caption: innovation so hack days workshops
Caption: connecting people together who want to
Caption: do the same type of training so you know
Caption: have an avenue we have channels on teams
Caption: and if people want to do AWS they post
Caption: on there I'm interested in this and then
Caption: when there's an AWS workshop coming up
Caption: we connect all those people so they can
Caption: do it together
Caption: because everything's more fun with a
Caption: team right also team-building events and
Caption: social club events we went to timezone
Caption: recently I read if I we have a tall
Caption: company back to base once a quarter and
Caption: so everyone comes together and learns
Caption: and has a bit of fun once a year the
Caption: whole company once a year the whole
Caption: company flies to a resort ivory switch
Caption: is a little bit OTT but the simple
Caption: cost-effective things like Friday drinks
Caption: a Friday lunch or end-of-month drinks
Caption: morning teas fundraisers fitness
Caption: activities there's so many different
Caption: things that you can do it's it's just
Caption: about somebody putting a structure in
Caption: place and engaging people's families I'm
Caption: a really big believer in this one and I
Caption: think a lot of companies don't do it you
Caption: know it's hard even to get a partner
Caption: allowed to come to a Christmas party
Caption: nowadays because of budget you know but
Caption: people's families are there when they've
Caption: had a tough week when they're working
Caption: overtime when they're stressed out it's
Caption: their families that are there to support
Caption: them if their families that they're
Caption: going and talking to and they're
Caption: thinking about leaving or taking another
Caption: job engage with their families not just
Caption: because you want them on your side so
Caption: people stay it is a bonus but but
Caption: because it's about a sense of community
Caption: when you have events and people's
Caption: families are coming they get to know
Caption: each other in my previous company had
Caption: igneel one of the things that was really
Caption: cool is that because we had so many
Caption: people that had moved to Australia from
Caption: other places they all became friends
Caption: outside of work so they'd go camping and
Caption: fishing and they do stuff you know
Caption: outside together as well and that was
Caption: really awesome and it helped us as a
Caption: company become a best place to work as
Caption: well so it's a win-win for all of us and
Caption: then the last bit is creating a culture
Caption: of gratitude and shouting out great work
Caption: so it's great to say thanks verbal
Caption: thanks it's awesome but having a
Caption: recognition wall having an awards
Caption: program a lot of companies do like it
Caption: quarterly or an annual award but more
Caption: than that it needs to be more regular so
Caption: ratify we use a shout out wall
Caption: this is just a really easy way where
Caption: people can jump on and they can call out
Caption: transparently people who have helped
Caption: them out or have done something awesome
Caption: for the organization and you can
Caption: recognize teams as well and then it also
Caption: ties into an awards program and then we
Caption: can choose how often we give tangible
Caption: rewards out of that as the leadership
Caption: team but people are still having that
Caption: just gratitude environment as a HR
Caption: person or a manager as well the ROI for
Caption: a best place to work award to have
Caption: something like this is as huge as well
Caption: it was one of the things called out in
Caption: our feedback of why we won an award so
Caption: many of you know a lot of this stuff
Caption: already I feel like a lot of that stuff
Caption: is a rocket science so I'm not trying to
Caption: tell people to suck eggs
Caption: my hope is just to inspire you to
Caption: continue improving and implementing more
Caption: things to make your workplace is the
Caption: best place to work because my dream is
Caption: that everybody loves what they do the
Caption: same way that I love what I do and so
Caption: when you go back to your workplaces next
Caption: week have a look but mostly have a
Caption: listen and then think about how you can
Caption: help make it a better place to work
Caption: [Applause]